hace ya algunos vídeos teníamos una
transformación lineal ese que iba de
algún subconjunto x de rn a algún
subconjunto y de rm y también tenemos
una transformación lineal t que iba de y
en un subconjunto de ahora digamos rl c
está bien entonces nosotros definimos lo
que era la composición de t con s como
una transformación que iba desde x
directamente hasta zeta y lo que era era
simplemente está compuesta con ese t
compuesta con ese aplicada a un vector x
era sencillamente tomar ese aplicársela
al vector x y al resultado aplicarle t
así que esta fue nuestra definición para
la composición de t con s y es más
nosotros vimos que si esa era
representada por la matriz
es decir s de x era igual a una matriz a
por el vector x y tx era representada
por la matriz b
o sea te de equis ser igual que la
matriz b por el vector x entonces
nosotros vimos que esta composición t
compuesta con s pues por la definición
tiene que ser igual a la matriz ve
multiplicada por la matriz a por el
vector x y nosotros definimos el
producto de matrices de modo que esto de
aquí fuera igual a la matriz b por la
matriz
y esa nueva matriz por el vector x muy
bien todo eso era repaso ahora qué pasa
si considero tres transformaciones
nuevas voy a tras considerar la
transformación g que ge x
va a ser igual a una matriz a por el
vector x esta matriz ya no tiene nada
que ver con esta matriz a es una nueva
matriz
hdx
hdx era igual a la matriz b por el
vector x y también voy a tener una
última transformación efe
y f x va a ser igual a una matriz c por
el vector x bien así que tengo estas
tres transformaciones que necesariamente
como son el producto de una matriz por
un vector así son representadas tienen
que ser transformaciones lineales y lo
que me interesa ahora es considerar
quién es la composición de g compuesta
con h eso es una transformación lineal
ya lo vimos y eso a su vez compuesto con
efe quién es esa transformación de ahí y
voy a asumir que los dominios y las
imágenes de g hf están en son tales que
esta composición tenga sentido porque
para que la composición de t con s tenga
sentido el dominio de t tiene que estar
contenido en la imagen
pero bueno entonces
ok voy a tomar esto y aplicárselo a un
vector x muy bien y cuanto me da eso
pues vamos a ver qué me dice la
definición
la definición me dice que esto sería si
llamo a esta transformación mi
transformación t y esta de aquí va a ser
mi transformación ese entonces de
acuerdo con esta definición
esto sería que compuesta con h
esa transformación aplicada a el
resultado de aplicarle f x aplicada a
efe de x muy bien y quien es esto pues
de nuevo si ahora tengo esta como mi
transformación de esta como mi
transformación ese y todo esto como
director x entonces esto es lo mismo que
g d
h de f de x
muchas paréntesis aquí bien ahora
esto esto es lo mismo que tiene pues si
ahora me fijo primero en este caso acá
en hd fx
eso sería g
sé de quién pues h de fx por definición
es h compuesta con f
aplicada al vector x
sería g de eso pero ahora que ahora
tengo que
hello puedo pensar como mi
transformación te y todo esto como mi
transformación s y entonces esto debe
ser lo mismo que
compuesta con
h compuesta con efe y todo eso
todo esto está nueva transformación
aplicada al vector x bueno y quizá se
estén preguntando para que me tome la
molestia de hacer todo esto para que
partir de acá y hice todas estas
igualdades para llegar a esto pues esto
todo esto fue para probar que la
composición de transformaciones
satisface la propia asociativa eso en
otras palabras lo único que quiere decir
aunque suene muy rimbombante es que no
importa en donde ponga mis paréntesis no
importa como acomoda y los paréntesis en
esta composición siempre me da lo mismo
en otras palabras lo que quiere decir es
que no importa si primero compongo ag
con h
y eso lo compongan con efe o si primero
compongo h con f
y eso lo compongo con g en otras
palabras estas dos cosas son
equivalentes a
compuesta con h compuesta con efe y toda
esta transformación aplicada al vector x
y no me importa el orden de los
paréntesis bien y ahora que sé que
esencialmente no importa cuáles dos
transformaciones de estas tres yo
componga primero quiero saber qué sucede
con la representación matricial de eso
es decir yo sé que si tengo
transformaciones existe representadas
por matrices a ive entonces la
composición de t con s es representada
por la matriz de por donde ve
representate y a representar ese
entonces qué pasa con la siguiente qué
pasa con qué compuesta con h el
resultado de eso compuesto con efe y eso
aplicado a el vector x pues por un lado
yo sé que eje x es lo mismo que
multiplicar a la matriz a por el vector
x que es representada por la matriz
h es representada por la matriz b
y f es representada por la matriz ce así
que estos de aquí sería lo mismo que
pues quien es la matriz que representa
que compuesta con h simplemente es el
producto de las matrices que representan
a g y h respectivamente es decir eso
primero es la matriz a por la matriz b
y ahora tienes la matriz que representa
a esta composición a la composición de g
con h compuesta con f la matriz que
representa g compuesta con h es la
matriz ave y la matriz que representa f
es la matriz ce así que la matriz que
representa a toda esta composición es
sencillamente la matriz a por ve
multiplicada por la matriz ce y todo eso
todo esto lo voy a multiplicar por el
vector x
bien
y qué me dice esta parte de abajo pues
nosotros color ahora voy a hacerlo así
compuesta con h compuesta con efe y todo
eso aplicado al vector x pues de nuevo
que matriz representa a esta composición
pues en primer lugar que matriz
representa la composición de h con efe
que sería la primera que haría pues la
composición de h con f está representado
por la matriz b por la matriz c es decir
h compuesta con f se representa por la
matriz bs
muy bien pero yo quiero ag compuesta con
h compuesta con efe así que necesito
multiplicar por la izquierda por la
matriz que representa g pero la matriz
que representa que está así que esto de
aquí es representado por la matriz
por la matriz de porsche ok y todo eso
toda esta matriz la debo multiplicar por
el vector
x
muy bien pero en este vídeo que fue lo
que vimos pues vimos que estas dos cosas
que esta composición y esta eran la
misma son iguales así que estas dos
cosas
como son iguales para todas x deben ser
iguales la matriz
ave por la matriz ce debe ser igual a la
matriz a por la matriz de porsche
y entonces cómo puedo omitir los
paréntesis porque no importa cuáles dos
multiplique primero esto debe ser igual
a la matriz a por b por c y yo elijo si
primero multiplicó a con b y eso lo
multiplicó con este o así 1º multiplicó
a beyoncé y eso lo multiplicó por a
porque noten a pesar de que por ejemplo
aquí parezca que estoy componiendo tres
cosas en realidad solo estoy componiendo
de dos en dos
esto me diría o primero componer que con
h ya eso lo compone con efe o 1º
compones h con efe ya eso lo compone con
g pero no puedo componer estas tres
cosas simultáneamente y esta propiedad
de que no importa el orden en el que
haga las cosas se conoce como la
propiedad
asociativa
asociativa del producto de matrices así
que en general cuando multiplicamos más
de dos matrices no tenemos que
preocuparnos por cómo hacemos esta
multiplicación cualquier elección que
nosotros hagamos cualesquiera decidamos
multiplicar primero nos va a dar el
mismo resultado con lo que sí tenemos
que tener cuidado porque ya vimos es con
el orden del producto es decir en
general la matriz a por una matriz b es
distinto de la matriz b por la matriz a
de hecho en algún vídeo hace poco vimos
que a veces alguno de estos dos pueden
no estar definido es decir que la matriz
a por la matriz b nos dé algo y que la
matriz b por la matriz a ni siquiera
esté definido las matrices no tienen la
propiedad conmutativa y bueno en el
próximo vídeo ver en la propia
distributiva del producto de matrices